[MUSIC PLAYING]
WALTER BRILL: So
thank you for coming.
We got the coolest
people at I/O right here.
[APPLAUSE] s
Give yourselves a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
Excellent.
So thank you for joining me.
We're going to dig into
the world of persona.
First, I want to
see a show of hands.
How many people brought a
persona with them today?
Great.
It's a trick question.
You all did.
Oh, I better get the clicker.
So we're going to talk
about how persona can
make your actions stand out.
They can extend the brand, and
they can increase usability.
First, I'm Wally Brill.
I'm the head of conversation
design advocacy and education
here at Google, and I've
been teaching robots
to talk for about 20 years.
Actually, I've been teaching
them to talk longer than that.
But when I was a kid,
they didn't talk back,
which was kind of depressing.
So this is a previous
persona of mine.
I even had hair.
I just want to tell you folks--
there is no distinct correlation
between hair loss and designing
personas.
It's OK.
All right.
So years ago, when I had
hair, I was a record producer.
I was working mostly in the UK.
And I had this idea--
whether it was good
or not, I'm not sure.
But I wanted to create an
opera that was interactive.
I wanted you to be able to talk
to the characters and change
plots, like one of those "Choose
Your Own Adventure" stories.
So what did I do?
I decided I would
find a technology that
would work to do this.
And in those days,
we were thinking
about things like CD-ROMs.
I don't know if any of
you remember CD-ROMs.
Yeah.
Oh, I see a nod.
I see a couple of nods.
OK, good.
Phew.
So I went to the company that
invented speech recognition,
and I said to them, can you
tell me about this stuff.
And they said, well,
you know about sound.
Come in here.
And they made me
take a job there.
And what happened was
they sent me to see
a man called James Giangola.
I don't know if any
of you know of him.
He was one of the pioneers
of conversational design
for interactive speech.
And he gave a talk at Stanford,
which completely blew my mind,
because it was about how you
can speak naturally to a robot,
and it will speak
naturally back to you.
He wrote a book called
"Voice User Interface
Design," which I
recommend to anybody
who's interested in this stuff.
So moving along, this is our
fabulous conversation design
team that I recently
joined at Google.
Lots of happy faces there.
Now let's get down to it.
What's a persona?
How do we go about designing the
perfect digital employee that's
going to work for us
and make us stand out?
So what is a persona?
It's the aspect of
someone's character
that's presented or
perceived by others.
It's your face that
you show to the world.
It's the who of who you are
that you let people see.
Now, in acting, people
use personas all the time.
In the 1930s, Leslie
Howard and Norma Shearer
did a version of
"Romeo and Juliet"
that was very successful.
It was very widely
liked, and it did well.
Now spin on to the 1990s.
And here's Leonardo
DiCaprio and Claire Danes
performing exactly
the same content
but with very
different personas.
And it came across very
much more contemporary.
And it was a big
success at the time
but very, very different
from that original film.
Now, everybody's got
a unique persona.
You get it when you're born.
It changes with you as you
develop and as you grow.
And like I say it's
the who of who you are.
It differentiates
us one from another
and makes us individuals.
But now we live in the future.
There are 500 million
devices that have
the Google Assistant on them.
500 million.
Can I get an OK?
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
Right.
That's a lot of people.
It's a lot of devices too.
So people have high
expectations of what
an intelligent assistant
can do and how and where we
can interact with it.
And it's not just this
thing that you talk to.
Now we're talking about surfaces
that the AI moves across
effortlessly from your
Google Home to your TV
to your smartphone to
your car to your watch.
All these surfaces we have to
take into consideration when
we're designing persona.
See?
It's not just voice.
It's also audio content,
like sound design.
It's visual content now.
It's interaction design.
The interaction design
actually has a lot
to do with how your
persona comes across.
And it's even typography.
Here's a quick example.
This is a joke.
I'm not holding up any hope
for it being a great joke,
but you can see that the punch
line is really punched up
because of typography.
So we got to think about
visual surfaces as well
as audio situations.
So let's pivot for a
second and now talk
about a voice-first
world and understand why
persona design is so important.
So we're going to talk
about a series of documents
that you will make when
you're designing a persona,
and what they'll do is
they'll help you keep
the writing, the things
that this system says,
consistent and clear
because, otherwise, it
can appear fractured.
And if the persona's
fractured, people
lose trust in the actual action.
So in "Wired for Speech"--
oh, sorry.
There is no such thing as
no persona, by the way.
That was my trick
question I stuck in there.
There we go.
In "Wired for Speech,"
Cliff Nass and Scott Brave
said when people
hear any voice, they
automatically and unconsciously
assign a personality to it.
This is a really
important thing.
Within a second, second and
a half of hearing a voice,
you create an
image in your mind.
You have an idea of who
you're listening to.
You know what I mean?
So whenever you hear--
somebody calls you up
that you don't know.
You've got an idea
of who they are.
You have a sense of them
because you know what?
We can infer age.
We can infer gender.
We understand their
educational level
by the kind of things they say.
We get register.
Now, register is
the social context.
It's where this persona
is in relation to me.
Is it my boss?
Is it my employee?
Is it my peer?
Who is this that
I'm speaking with?
We also get a sense of locale
if they have an accent that's
different from ours.
We just don't recognize accents
if we have the same one.
So the other inferred
traits we get
are intelligence,
trustworthiness,
and likability.
All these things come through
in that first second, second
and a half of hearing a voice,
so it's really important
that we get this right.
We have to set ourselves
up for success because now,
more than ever, the
experience of the action
is the brand to the consumer.
What happens is every
touchpoint matters.
So billboard advertising,
the web, radio, TV,
social media-- absolutely
every touchpoint
carries the brand essence.
And so it's vital
that we get it right
because if we
leave it to chance,
you never know what
you're going to get.
So you don't just use anything.
You've got to
design your persona
because, otherwise, the
results will be unpredictable.
So how do we do it?
How do we actually design one?
This is where some of
the fun stuff starts.
We need to make that
digital employee.
And what I've done
is I've suggested
we take two airlines
to map this out
and to talk about how we do it.
These are two airlines that,
obviously, don't exist.
One is Important Airlines.
It's a national carrier.
It's important.
You can see their strapline.
"We're important, and
we will get you there."
Kind of traditional.
Kind of straight.
On the other hand, there's
Millennial Airlines.
And their strapline is "It's
an awesome day to fly!"
Do you want to say that with me?
It's an awesome day to fly!
Once more with feeling.
Great.
Thank you.
Phew.
(LAUGHS)
So the first step in
designing a persona
is we need to
understand the brand.
We need to interview
the stakeholders.
We need to talk
to people in brand
and marketing, in customer
experience, customer service.
We want to look to see
if there's a style guide.
Now, the marketing people
and the brand people
will have already done this.
They'll have distilled
their brand down.
But you want to go over it and
understand it and really get
it.
So you're going to
experience the product too.
You're going to get on the plane
and go take a trip somewhere.
You may visit the Contact Center
because those Contact Center
agents are actually carrying
the brand essence with them when
they speak to customers
over the phone.
You're going to check
out social media.
And if there's a
retail component,
you'll go into a store.
So let's talk about
Important for a second.
Let's talk about my
water for a second.
Here it is.
So Important Airlines'
brand is solid.
They're confident.
They're experts.
They know what they're doing.
They're reliable.
They're utterly straightforward.
There's no frills or anything.
And they're safe.
They've got a great
safety record.
But you're not going
to get wildly excited
flying on Important.
No surprises.
Now, Millennial, on
the other hand, where
it's an awesome day to fly--
thank you for
helping me with that.
The Millennial
Airlines' brand is bold.
It's hip.
It's fun.
It's friendly.
It's even exciting
and delightful.
It's a whole different
kind of world.
It's there to bring excitement
of travel into your life.
So those are two sets
of brand essences.
Now let's understand
the customer.
We need to know who's going
to use this interaction.
So we want to understand their
context and their customer
journey.
We want to know who they are
through their demographics.
Where do they live?
What are they like?
How old are they?
We want to understand the
frequency of engagement
because that's
going to have a lot
to do with how verbose
your prompts are.
If they're frequent,
frequent users,
you can keep things
really short.
If they're infrequent
users, you might
want to give them a
little more information.
And we want to understand
their expectations and needs.
Now, one thing you should
know is that people generally
like to be mirrored.
They like the idea
of interacting
with someone who at least
relates to them in some ways.
It's a preference.
So the Important
Airlines' customer--
mid-30s and up.
These are business travelers.
They're frequent,
frequent flyers.
They're road warriors.
They're high value because those
business class and first class
seats are expensive.
Whereas, on the other hand,
our Millennial customer
is late teens to mid-30s.
They're Millennials.
They're holidaymakers.
They're backpackers.
They're young families
going to Orlando, maybe.
They're budget conscious, and
they don't use the airline
very much.
They use it for holidays
once or twice a year.
So we know the brand.
We know the customer.
Now, what task are
we going to do here?
So what I've chosen is
flyfo, flight information--
that's what's the
status of my flight--
is it going to take off
on time, is it late,
has it been canceled,
when is it expected--
all that kind of good stuff--
which leads us to choosing
the medium for the audio.
Now, there's two
ways to do this.
You can use text
to speech, TTS--
I'm sure you all
know what that is--
versus custom
recording, which is
when you have an actor in
front of a microphone recording
prompts.
Text to speech is the
computer-generated voice.
Custom recording
is the human actor.
So text to speech is
infinitely scalable.
It's really easy to use.
It's really cheap
because what it's doing
is it's reading written content.
It handles dynamic
content really well.
So in our case,
we've got an airline
with a lot of changes going on--
Duluth to Minneapolis,
blah blah blah--
all these things that are going
and stuff changing on the fly,
so we'll probably use
text to speech there.
Oh.
Can you go back one please?
There we go.
The cons are limited
voice availability.
And occasionally, you'll hear--
I think Sundar mentioned
this in the keynote--
you hear prosody.
And the prosody is
the melody of speech.
And occasionally--
certainly in the old days--
text to speech
prosody wasn't great.
I think you'll agree from what
we heard this week that it's
now phenomenally good.
It's almost indistinguishable
from human speech.
So "Time Out" magazine
in London decided
they would use text to speech.
They do listings of events,
whatever is hip and happening.
As you can see,
Sanjay Vikal said,
"From secret tango
lessons to breakfast
raves, using the Assistant
to connect Time Out visitors
to the coolest stuff to do."
And they do.
They created Tio,
who is a Millennial.
She's hip and happening.
She knows what's going on
in London at any given time.
Let me give you an example
of what she sounds like.
OK, Google.
Talk to Time Out.
[APP CHIMES]
TIO: Hey, you again.
Got a quiet week ahead.
Not anymore.
When do you want
to go out-- today,
this week, or this weekend?
WALTER BRILL: Who are you?
TIO: I'm Tio.
No one knows the city
like me because I've
been discovering the brilliant
and searching out the secrets
and extraordinary
for a long time.
If you want to know about food,
arts, culture, and nightlife,
then I am your social companion.
Try me.
What do you want to do and
when do you want to do it?
WALTER BRILL:
Where are you from?
TIO: In West Kensington,
born and raised.
On the estate was where
I spent most of my days,
chilling out, maxing,
relax and all hipster,
skating so much that
I would get a blister.
With a couple of
mates, I'd go out
on the town, started seeing
my bank balance go down.
I got into debt, and my
mom started to shout.
She said, "You need to get a
job at a place called Time Out."
What else do you want to do?
WALTER BRILL: Quit.
[APP CHIMES]
It's pretty cool, right?
It's pretty interesting.
That's a pretty solid
persona, and you get
a sense of who she really is.
Now, on the custom
recording side,
Headspace, which does
meditation guidance,
needed to use an actual real
voice, Andy Puddicombe, who is
the guy who started Headspace.
And he does guided meditations.
And I won't play one now because
they chill me out so much,
I couldn't carry
on with this talk.
But they're really, really good.
And the thing about custom
recording is it's natural.
It's expressive.
It's comprehensible.
And any voice in the
world can be used.
You can go and hire anybody
to be the voice actor.
Now, luckily for Headspace,
they've got Andy.
He's there all the time
because sometimes it
can be expensive to
record and maintain,
and it relies on the
availability of that artist.
Andy goes there every
day, so he's OK.
So let me play you an example
of Headspace, just a short one
to hear what the
voice sounds like.
[APP CHIMES]
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Hi.
My name's Andy, and
welcome to Headspace.
Using proven meditation
and mindfulness techniques,
I'll show you how to train your
mind for a healthier, happier,
more enjoyable life.
To get started, try one
of our short sessions.
They're each under
two minutes long.
They can help bring a
little more mindfulness
into your life.
There are three options
to choose from--
Wake Up, Take a
Moment, or Unwind.
Which one would you like to try?
WALTER BRILL: OK.
Now, because we're doing flight
information, we've chosen TTS.
So the fun part.
How do we design this persona?
How do we create that
perfect representative,
our digital employee?
What are the steps
we have to take?
This is where we get creative.
Dig into that creative
brain, and let's get going.
So we go back to the airlines.
We understand the brand,
the customer, the task,
and the medium.
Now we're going to go
and invent some people.
We're going to write biographies
for imaginary characters who
might be a good fit for the
job that we have for them.
So who's that perfect
representative?
Who can it be?
They got to make the
action useful and usable.
They've got to be
comprehensible.
They've got to be somebody that
you'd really want to work with.
The first step is register.
We need to know what
that social context is.
We talked about this
a little bit before.
What's the relationship
between me and that persona?
Is it my peer, a really
close friend of mine?
Is it an employee,
somebody that works for me
and just does whatever I
ask whenever I need it?
Or is it an advisor, somebody
who maybe knows more stuff
than me, is at somewhat
of a higher level,
and that I'm taking
information from?
Now, when we do this
for real, you'll
probably want to create
three different personas.
And you may make them of three
different registers-- ones
appear, maybe two are employees.
You'll play around
with it a little bit,
and you'll make the
register different for them.
Now have a look at this chart.
This, again, comes
from Clifford Nass.
And you'll see that there's
a vertical axis, which
is dominance and submissiveness
versus friendliness
and distance.
This is kind of
handy because when
you are deciding what
kind of persona you want
and how it's going to
relate to your customer,
you can use this quite
effectively to position them.
Now, for Important
Airlines, we decided
we wanted a butler,
somebody like a butler,
who would relate to that
demographic that we had.
Remember, they're 35 and
up, so we wanted somebody
with some gravitas.
I'll give it no hints, but
it's a British airline.
And so we wanted a sort
of concierge character
that you could trust.
So we have Terrence Butler.
He's 56.
His occupation is butler.
He comes from Bromley in Kent,
which is a lovely suburb.
Now, why do I care about
his height and weight?
Because it affects voice.
It affects the
largeness of the voice
versus the smallness
of the voice,
so there's a lot in
there in terms of size.
He's solidly built. He's
got thinning silver hair.
That's just a
shout-out to people
who are losing their hair.
He lives where he works.
He's single.
And he went to the Ivor
Spencer International School
for Butler Administrators,
which is a real place.
Can you believe it?
Phenomenal.
Carrying on, he's a
collector of rare wines.
Why do we care?
Because he's detail oriented.
His parents-- Jack was
a retired hotel manager,
so he understands the
hospitality industry.
His mother was a retired nurse--
again, a caretaking profession.
So he doesn't have any siblings.
The reason we're
interested in siblings
is if you're the
oldest of four kids,
you may be a little
better at being
a caretaker than the youngest.
And my family actually
works that way.
I'm the youngest, and
I'm a little crazy.
But my eldest brother
is very straight ahead.
What does he like to watch?
He likes to watch "Upstairs,
Downstairs," "Downton Abbey."
He reads "The Daily Telegraph"
and historical fiction
by Hilary Mantel.
He's also been 30 years in this
job, so he really knows it.
Now we flash back to the
brand attributes of Important
and see how they match up.
So Important is solid.
It's confident.
It's expert.
It's reliable.
It's straightforward.
It's safe.
So how does Terrence
relate to that?
Well, he's a butler.
He's been a butler
for a long time.
He's confident.
He's expert.
And he's reliable.
He's very straightforward.
And he's worked for that
family for over 30 years,
so he's somebody you can trust.
And the fact that he's an
avid collector of rare wines
tells you that he is detail
oriented, and he is an expert.
Now, the next step is
we're going to create--
beyond this bio, we're going
to create two more documents.
We're going to create
a monologue, which
gives us a sense of
who this character is.
It's a paragraph, like a
conversation that they're
having with a friend
in a bar or somewhere,
where they're just telling
them something that
happened that day or that week.
And it's really just to
get us into the character
a little more deeply.
And if you're using custom
recording with voice actors,
it's a great way for them to
dive back into the character
if they've recorded
that monologue once,
because on Monday, they
may be in the studio
recording for a sausage
company, and on Tuesday, they
may be doing a car commercial.
But on Thursday, they're
coming in to do your action,
and you want them to
be in your persona.
So that's why these
materials really help.
The monologue really helps.
So let me give you
an example of one.
TERRENCE BUTLER: I quite
enjoy this occupation.
It's extremely gratifying to
know that one is indispensable.
If Sir is stepping
out of an evening,
I shall have prepared Sir's
dinner jacket and accessories.
And I shall, of course, assist
him in tying his bow tie.
The work of a gentleman's
gentleman is never done.
WALTER BRILL: So
he's pretty formal.
His language is pretty formal.
And the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to create
a sample dialogue.
Now, I know that all
of you-- whenever
you decide to make an
action or create an action,
you start with conversation.
You start with sample dialogues.
You write the conversation
out like a two-part play.
Here's the user.
Here's the system.
And that really
helps to tell you
whether this conversation
is natural sounding.
So here's Terrence in
an actual interaction
the way he would be if he
were working in the action.
OK, Google.
Talk to Important Airlines.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Getting
Important Airlines.
TERRENCE BUTLER: Good morning.
You're through to
Important Airlines.
Am I speaking with Wally?
WALTER BRILL: That's right.
TERRENCE BUTLER: Thank you.
And do you require information
regarding your flight to London
today?
WALTER BRILL: Yes.
And do you require information
regarding your flight to London
today-- very formal language,
very much in persona,
very much locked
into what we would
expect for this character.
Now let's move along
and go to Millennial,
which is, as we know, a very
different airline indeed.
So the Millennial
Airlines' persona
is a young woman we
call Helen Highwater.
I'll say that again.
Helen Highwater.
She's 26 years old.
She's a gate agent at San
Francisco International.
She comes from Mill
Valley, California,
another nice suburb.
She's 5' 5", 115 pounds.
The general physical
description shows
that she's kind of a hipster.
She's got this wild
asymmetrical haircut.
She lives in a three-bedroom
apartment in the Mission with
a couple of friends of hers--
Jack, who's a
software developer,
interestingly enough, and
Natalie, who's in med school.
She's going out with Gary,
who's a drummer in a band called
The Ironic Three.
Now, the reason
they're ironic is
because there are five members.
She studied drama and English,
which gives her a lot of help
towards what she really wants to
be, which is a stand-up comic.
That's her dream.
She spends every free
minute working on her act.
So her parents--
Ron manages the Mill Valley
branch of the Bank of Marin,
so she has a certain
sense of responsibility.
Lucy teaches English lit at Mill
Valley Middle school, so again,
a love of language.
These all kind of factor in.
And you may think some of these
things are not that necessary,
but I promise you, if you get
into a studio with a voice
artist, they're going to go
thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
This gives me some depth
that gives me something
to work with.
She doesn't have any siblings.
Her work history was that she
was a bartender at Cobbs Comedy
Club.
She likes "Game of
Thrones," "Stranger Things,"
"Broad City," Dua Lipa,
Amy Schumer, Amy Sedaris--
all the good stuff.
Now go back to the brand.
This brand is bold,
hip, fun, happening.
They're friendly.
They're exciting.
And they're delightful.
I think she could be a
really good match for this.
So let's see how
she ties up for it.
26-year-old hipster.
She's hip.
She works as a gate agent in
San Francisco International.
She's done it for three
years without missing a day.
She's reliable.
We can count on her.
She's a people person.
She gets along with
everybody, even drummers.
That makes her friendly and fun.
And her dream is to make
a living as a stand-up.
Now, if you're going to be a
stand-up, you better be bold.
You better be friendly.
You better be fun.
And please be delightful.
So she's got a monologue.
Let's have a listen.
HELEN HIGHWATER:
I use everything.
And believe me, when you
deal with the passengers,
there's endless
amounts of material,
like the woman who
was going to Boston,
but her luggage was
on its way to Austin,
or the parents
off on holiday who
each expected the other one to
bring the kids to the airport.
Then there's the guy who
thinks he deserves an upgrade
because he was in some obscure
rock band from 20 years ago
or something.
Let me tell you, it's great
training for a stand-up,
and I get paid for it.
And if I can deal
with them, there
isn't a heckler in the
world who can bother me.
WALTER BRILL: So
pretty consistent.
She is who she is.
We get a sense of her
through the monologue.
Now let's see what she would
be like in a sample dialogue
actually doing the job.
OK, Google.
Talk to Millennial Airlines.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Getting
Millennial Airlines.
[APP CHIMES, PLAYS MUSIC]
HELEN HIGHWATER:
Millennial Airlines.
It's an awesome day to fly.
Is this Wally?
WALTER BRILL: Yep.
HELEN HIGHWATER: Great.
Do you want info about your
flight to London today?
WALTER BRILL: That's right.
So completely different kind
of language-- do you want info,
it's an awesome day to fly--
very different than our
last persona, Terrence,
because these brands
are so different.
And we need to be
consistent to the brand.
So as you can see, it
makes a difference.
So in terms of
positioning these guys,
where do we think they
would fit on this chart?
Well, let's start with Terrence.
He's kind of submissive.
He's introverted.
He just does what he's told.
He does the job.
He does it very, very
well, but he does the job.
He's not overly friendly.
He's not distant.
He's just kind of in that
middle place somewhere.
And what about Helen?
She's super friendly.
She's an extrovert
to the extreme,
and she's a lot of fun.
So she belongs right
there over on the right.
The next step, which
we're not going
to dive into too
deeply right now,
is what we call user testing.
Sometimes you do what's
called Wizard of Oz testing.
And you can do this
effectively with dialogue
flow by actually
mocking up, quickly,
the main pass of
your interactions
and then playing
them for people,
have people work
through them and get
a sense of how usable it is and
how much that persona matches
their ingoing expectations.
So we got a few
takeaways for you.
First, review the actions
you've already made.
And they're wonderful, I know.
But is the persona
clearly defined?
Do you feel confident
that that persona is
well imagined and well created?
Is it representative of the
brand, the user, and the task?
Does it work right?
Number two-- define
that persona.
You're going to follow the
process, learn about the brand,
know the user, know
the task, and define
appropriate characters, which
is, for me, the fun part.
And then bring it to life.
Write these monologues.
Write these sample dialogues.
And make recordings of
them because you can only
tell about conversational
voice user interface
by listening to it.
If you read it on
the page, it won't
have the same effect at all.
And if you've got
stakeholders that you're
trying to talk to
about what you're doing
and to explain this is the right
thing, they've got to hear it.
You don't want to give them
anything with writing on it.
Just say close your eyes.
Listen to this.
And then test.
Test your action
with real customers--
low-fidelity prototypes,
dialogue flow, however.
But you want to derive
some data and some proof
points for your stakeholders
to say customers,
users really felt this
was right for our brand.
And that gives you
success, I hope.
I'm sure.
And it will be wonderful.
And you'll make
beautiful personas.
And so with that,
I'm going to ask
you to give us some feedback.
You all know the drill.
And finally, here are a couple
of resources that are really
quite wonderful--
developers.google.com,
google.com/io.
Cathy Pearl, who just
recently joined our team,
wrote a wonderful book
called "Designing Voice User
Interfaces," which
I recommend highly.
Clifford Nass's book,
"Wired for Speech,"
I also recommend highly.
He talks about persona
at great, great length.
And James Giangola's "Voice
User Interface Design"
is a really, really
important baseline book.
This kicked off a whole
generation of UI designers.
So with that, thank you
very, very much for coming,
and have a wonderful
rest of I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]